bonsoir mardi 13 octobre bienvenue dans
le journal de la rédaction de tv 78
voici les titres de cette édition
seize collectivités des yvelines
labellisé centre de préparation aux jeux
olympiques de 2024 ces sites
accueilleront les athlètes pour leur
entraînement pré compétition
reportage à guyancourt et aux clayes
sous bois et puis invités en plateau
jean claude redon président du comité
olympique et sportif des yvelines
le département compte une nouvelle
sénatrice thuan bora jusqu'à présent
maire de saint-rémy l'honorer entre dans
la chambre haute
elle remplace alain schmitz en poste
depuis 2010 était démissionnaire il
conférence de presse se tenait hier à
rambouillet en présence de gérard
larcher
enfin au niveau national elle s'est
achevée hier mais pas de panique la fête
de la science se poursuivre jusqu'à
jeudi à saint quentin en yvelines
le week-end dernier la commanderie
située à elancourt accueillait un
village d'animations dédiées retour dans
ce journal
également le bilan de la semaine du
handicap à montigny le bretonneux
c'était au programme du 5 au 11 octobre
[Musique]
elles seront donc une quinzaine de
collectivités heavy nasa avoir un centre
de préparation pour les jo de 2024 c'est
ce qui a été annoncé le 30 septembre
dernier par le comité d'organisation des
jeux de paris parmi les communes
retenues guyancourt et les
clayes-sous-bois reportages et réactions
sur place d'eléonore sinoquet de nicolas
kirillovitch 16 collectivités 19
équipements été retenue pour devenir des
centres de préparation pour les athlètes
en 2024 les yvelines auront donc la part
belle pour le grand rendez vous sportif
que sont les jeux olympiques
le gymnase maurice baquet de guyancourt
recevra les entraînements de judo pour
accueillir les sportifs la ville a lancé
la construction de deux salles d'arts
martiaux
les travaux devraient s'achever en juin
coût de l'opération 2 2 à 2 5 millions
d'euros subventionnés je pense que c'est
effectivement liée à ses nouvelles
installations qui vont arriver l'an
prochain et donc qui permettent un
confort d'installation on pense aussi à
la proximité du lieu olympiques puisque
le lyon olympique aura probablement lieu
pour le judo sous la tour eiffel
c'était un besoin vrai besoin pour la
ville de guyancourt de toute façon du
côté des clayes-sous-bois l'annoncent a
aussi été bien accueillie la commune a
été retenue pour sa piste de bmx situé
dans le parc du carillon est créée en
2010 est en remplacement un terrain de
football à notre site et en être
reconnue donc les équipes devront
choisir parmi les différents sites au
moment des jo
et bah nous espérons que nous serons le
choisi par une équipe de haut niveau et
pourquoi pas espérer l'équipe de france
si une vingtaine de lieux yves binois
est déjà connu d'autres dossiers sont
encore à l'étude comme l'athlétisme à
guyancourt 16 collectivités retenues
donc dans les yvelines comme centre de
préparation aux jeux olympiques de paris
dans les yvelines ce sont quatre villes
saint quentinois qui ont été
sélectionnés guyancourt et les
clayes-sous-bois aussi il est aussi
trappe et plaisir en ajoutant aussi
l'île de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines écoutez la réaction du
vice-président sport de l'agglomération
c'est une réelle reconnaissance pour 51
des villes puisque bien évidemment nous
sommes terre d'accueil des jeunes
nous avons le label terre d'accueil des
jeux olympiques nous avons aujourd'hui
quatre sites olympiques qui
accueilleront six épreuves mais nous
démontrons par le fait d'accueillir
bientôt les et les équipes qui viendront
en préparation pour ces jo le fait que
non seulement certes nous serons sûrs
des preuves mais nous sommes aussi un
lieu dans lequel on va par la qualité
nos équipements le kali de la qualité de
l'accueil des équipes pouvoir permettre
aux équipes de bien se préparer
ce qui prouve que non seulement la
qualité des équipements est reconnue
mais la qualité des sites également est
validée et ça le sera d'autant plus
efficace pour ensuite les épreuves elle
même et pour réagir également à cette
actualité j'accueille en plateau jean
claude redon bonsoir bonsoir
alors vous êtes le président du cnoss 78
c'est le comité départemental olympique
et sportif des yvelines déjà cette
nouvelle comment l'avez vous accueillez
ce qu'on peut dire que c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour les bleus recommandez vous
imaginez nous travaillons depuis pas mal
de mois sinon des années sur ce sujet
depuis que nous les olympiques ont été
donnés à paris alima donc en ya à peu
près deux ans maintenant
donc nous sommes d'immédiatement lancer
dans une autre préparation non seulement
sur les terrains on y reviendra sur les
terrains d'entraînement mais aussi sur
l'ensemble de la population
parce que vous ne l'imaginez bien qu' il
n'y a pas que 400 mille sportifs dans
département il ya un million cinq cent
mille habitants
il faut que tout le monde participe donc
je pense qu'on aura l'occasion
rapidement de revenir sur ce style rôle
sur votre voix l'insolence sociaux et
les jeux olympiques
elle est déjà associé donc on a déjà a
dit à propos de ces jeux qui avait aussi
des épreuves 1 qui allait être
accueillis sur le territoire des îles
c'est aussi on va en parler dans un
instant en tout on va le voir sur cette
animation sont prêts 19 disciplines 1 16
collectivités mais 19 disciplines en
tout qui pourront venir se préparer dans
les yvelines alors sur les athlètes en
de ces disciplines du football à
l'escrimé en passant par le bmx le
badminton le trampoline le volet et j'en
passe comment peut-on expliquer que le
département des yvelines compte autant
de centres de préparation est ce que
c'est la proximité avec paris où est ce
qu'on peut parler aussi de la qualité
des sites
oui mais je pense que j'ai un job je
m'attendais un petit peu à cette
question j'ai regardé il ya six cent
soixante six enfants en sont qu ils ont
été qualifiés pour faire cela et nous
avons 16 dans les yvelines c'est à peu
près le la moyenne mais vous avez 17
déciderait en nombre dans d'autres
départements qui sont très loin
car l'objectif du comité olympique qui
organise les jeux et de faire travailler
l'ensemble des populations sur le
terrain pour supporter l'idée que ça
peut apporter quelque chose aux
populations au delà des sportifs
du coup il mais c'est quelque chose de
voir exactement je crois que c'est un
point très important nous avons ces
tailleurs de tissus estanguet a mis
l'accent là dessus de nombreuses fois et
je pense c'est un élément qui a permis à
la france d'obtenir du jeu parce que
nous sommes sortis la du cadre habituel
de présentation de jeu sur une ville
c'est la france qui a agit donc c'est
très bien que nous en ayons 19 ans des
parfums 16 sites en département au delà
des sites de compétition eux-mêmes qui
sont déjà très intéressant voilà un trou
est ce que vous avez des informations
sur comment ça va fonctionner ces
centres de préparation concrètement les
athlètes pourront y venir d après les
jeux de tokyo ce que l'on peut dire sur
ce thème là c'est que déjà le
département en tant que puissance locale
nous a demandé de travailler avec eux à
la préparation de ces centres du coup
l'équipe sportive du département est
revenu vers nous et nous sommes sortis
sur les différentes huiles pour essayer
de qualifier des installations pour leur
dire présenter vos dossiers et puis vous
verrez bien en fonction des
installations vous avez qu'est-ce qui
peut être pré présentée et le retour
aujourd'hui et de ce nombre de quêtes
très important donc de la rue louise
savard notre rôle a été de faire la
préparation est de mettre en contact les
municipalités car elles sont détentrices
est propriétaire des terrains de sport
bien évidemment et le monde et le monde
olympique pour leur permettre de
présenter les dossiers alors les 16 qui
sont déjà qualifiés c'est très bien mais
il ya encore des villes qui sont en
cours de préparation
et aux dernières nouvelles le cojo est
tout à fait même de rouvrir de nouvelles
candidatures qui pour l'instant on avait
plutôt des blocages en lisant il
il n'est pas impossible qu'on arrête un
blouson comité d'organisation des jeux
qui est en train de dire et alors on va
plus loin et que nous avions fait
remonter cette demande sur le territoire
c'est que les clubs aujourd'hui souhaite
au delà des mairies un club s'il a la
puissance pour pouvoir le faire
voudrait aussi être rentré dans
l'opération en terre de jeux et
éventuellement site d'entraînement c'est
l'occasion aussi de parler de vos
missions alors très brièvement tu que le
temps file dans cette interview mais
concrètement à quoi sert un comité
départemental olympique et sportif bien
alors nous avons la mission qui nous est
délégué par le cnosf de représenter sur
le territoire des départements et il ya
un gain d'un gosse un comité
parlementaire départements en france
l'émission qui sont celles du comité
olympique ça passe par à l'époque une
présentation très forte vers l'animation
sportive et depuis quelques années cette
évolution d'ailleurs avec la création de
l'agencé à suspendre récemment avec les
fédérations avaient pris le lead sur cet
aspect là et nous nous sommes amenés à
faire de beaucoup plus d'opérations
transverse et vert je dirais un vocable
très important aujourd'hui qui est de
faire quelque chose vers le service
public et le vivre ensemble
du coup nous avons développé énormément
vélo sport santé le développement vers
le handicap
nos développements vers l'éco
responsabilité tout ceci en transverse
pour aider les fédérations qui elles
travaillent sur le chantier de leurs
activités sportives propre à faire en
sorte que le territoire sur lequel nous
sommes profitent de l'ensemble ce qui
n'était pas le cas la bière
habituellement c'est pour ça que je vous
ai dit d'ailleurs quatre cent mille
licenciés pour un million cinq cent
mille habitants dans les yvelines
ma mission c'est d'essayer de toucher
les 1 million cent mille autres parce
que elles font peut-être du sport mais
sans trop le dire
et là il ya un gisement énorme pour que
pour que nous puissions par ce biais là
je vous donne l exemple sur les sites
d'entraînement quand on a travaillé sur
les sites d'entraînement au bout de
quelques temps nous sommes rendu compte
qu'il fallait faire quelque chose sur le
tourisme
voilà un exemple d'apports extérieurs
avec lequel je n'avais jamais travaillé
et bien je suis en relation actuellement
avec le syndicat l'association des
syndicats tourisme du département pour
essayer de trouver des moyens
de fixer les personnes qui vont venir en
terre lilloise pour se préparer aux jeux
mais une fois qu'elles sont sorties de
leur terrain ou leur piscine qu'est ce
qu'elles font le reste de la journée
eh bien pourquoi pas faire quelque chose
sur l'impressionnisme dans les yvelines
je vous donne un exemple il y en a tant
d'autres à travailler sur les transports
travail oui il m'a dit qu'on s'a
l'objectif c'est de faire en sorte que
le concept des jeux ne soient pas un
événement ponctuel et qui disparaît le
soir où on a fermé là on a stoppé la
flamme il faut continuer à développer et
je pense que ça passe par là la
perception par la population et tour
d'où le poids des mairies parce que
c'est finalement monsieur le maire dans
une commune qui tient là l'animation de
sa ville on arrive malheureusement la
fin de cet entretien mais d'ici les jeux
je vous le promets on aura l'occasion de
reparler volontiers départemental
olympique et sportif les mêmes ce qui
s'appelle terre de jeux et keane qui
émanent aussi de dorny estanguet et je
reviendrai volontiers vous le présenter
et merci d'être venus en plateau jean
claude redon président du cnoss 78 les
jeux olympiques et paralympiques de 2024
objet aussi de critiques sur le
territoire les représentants d'europe
écologie les verts
saint-quentin-en-yvelines s'opposent
depuis de longs mois à la tenue de
l'épreuve de vtt sur la colline
d'elancourt le site saint quentinois
vient d'être confirmée récemment par le
comité d'organisation des jo
pour ses opposants les travaux
nécessaires à l'organisation d'un tel
événement et je cite d'après un
communiqué une folie environnementale
tant les risques sont nombreux et
importants pour cette colline je le
rappelle artificielle fruit de la
construction de la ville nouvelle
il ya 50 ans écoutez à ce propos le
coresponsable du parti à saint quentin
en yvelines les propos sont recueillis
par astrid berges heures et nicolas
kirillovitch d'un vélo route de sauve
avec des motos qui roulent dessus les
nathan destine serez colis n'est pas de
problème nous balade dessus à pieds de
problème ce qui pose un problème c'est
la mesure où fait des aménagements
urbains c'est qu'on commence à modifier
la colline et à creuser
à côté des fondations ça veut dire que
on va toucher la grille en profondeur on
va remuer les déchets qui ont été
enfouis et on sait pas aujourd'hui
quelle serait la réaction de ces déchets
ça fermente depuis depuis 50 ans on sait
pas ce qui peut se passer dans le reste
de l'actualité elle est devenue
sénatrice des yvelines depuis le 1er
octobre dernier toile bois remplace
alain schmitz démissionnaire pour la
maire de saint-rémy l'honorer qui devra
laisser très prochainement son mandat
municipal ce sera l'occasion de porter
la voix des élus locaux et de s'occuper
de plusieurs sujets au sein d'une
commission les précisions de nicolas
kirillovitch madame bora de la mairie de
saint rémy l'honorer au palais du
luxembourg il n'y a qu'un pas pour toi
de bora à 51 ans la maire de cette
commune est devenue sénatrice des
yvelines le 1er octobre 2020 c'est un
honneur une fierté d'y siéger de siéger
au palais du luxembourg de représenter
d'être au service de mon pays
toine bourg a obtenu ce nouveau mandat
suite à la démission d'alain schmitz
sénateur depuis 2010 est l ancien
président du conseil général de 2009 à
2014 a décidé de prendre du recul avec
la politique
je veux dire que la fuite se fait un
travail tout à fait exceptionnel au
sénat
en même temps il a été extrêmement
proche des communes des yvelines c'est
ça notre équilibre permanent ont trouvé
entre la réalité du territoire dans sa
diversité territoire français dans sa
diversité aussi se nourrir de nos
expériences locales pour enrichir les
textes nationaux dans cet équilibre
thuan bora siégera au sein de la
commission culture éducation et
communication aux côtés de son collègue
michel laugier tout en conservant cet
ancrage local essentiel dans le mandat
de sénateur souhaite être une sénatrice
active à l'écouté des élus une sénatrice
qui défendra les territoires si on
pouvait aller j'ai les choses afin que
les maires puissent être plus efficace
et plus réactif ben ce sera pour moi une
très grande chose évidemment réforme de
la décentralisation le plan de relance
ou encore la fiscalité locale pour 2021
prochains dossiers sur lesquels vont se
pencher les 348 parlementaires du palais
du luxembourg dont la nouvelle sénatrice
des yvelines thuan bourg
nicolas en cache un autre rallye
s'agissait bien d'un sujet de nicolas
d'andry dans le reste de l'actualité en
bref les policiers rassemblés à
versailles une cinquantaine de
fonctionnaires s'est réuni hier lundi
devant l'hôtel de police à l'appel du
syndicat unité sgp fo une mobilisation
seulement deux jours après l'attaqué du
commissariat de champigny sur marne dans
le 94 à la semaine dernière également
deux policiers de la drpj de versailles
avait essuyé des tirs à l'armé à feu
c'était à herblay dans le val d'oise est
les manifestants dénoncent une montée de
la violence envers les forces de l'ordre
à montigny le bretonneux la ville
organisait du 5 au 11 octobre dernier la
17e semaine du handicap des ateliers de
sensibilisation était proposé aux
scolaires ainsi que des jeux à faire en
famille comme les activités organisées
samedi dernier c'était au gymnase pierre
de coubertin à montigny le bretonneux le
retour avec mélanie poké et patrick
jacques de dixmude nous permettre une
prise de conscience avec sa semaine du
handicap la ville de montigny le
bretonneux sensibilise depuis 17 ans à
tous les handicaps moteurs mentaux ou
encore psychique permettre une forme
d'inclusion à long terme on va le
travail encore extrêmement long et
normand poursuit on poursuit la démarche
et on espère que
sur le long terme les choses fort en
leurs propres ailes des ateliers pour
les scolaires et les enfants mais aussi
une mise en avant du sport adapté
cette semaine c'est aussi l'occasion du
12e tournoi de hand fauteuil
quatre équipes en tout avec des équipes
vraiment de très très bon niveau
donc on à caen qui est venue jouer les
tours
nous avons vernon et l'équipe de
montigny avec le co vide on est déjà
enchanté d'avoir pu maintenir le tournoi
compte tenu des difficultés que peuvent
avoir certaines régions une 17e édition
qui avait choisi de prendre de la
hauteur avec la grimpe adapté encadrés
par l'association ciel on a ouvert cette
section parce que on s'est rendu compte
que l'autisme l escalade faisait
vraiment bon ménage
moi ça fait dix ans que jean cadre de
l'escale adapté dans mon île m avec ma
compagne notamment et on a eu des
résultats assez surprenants dans les
championnats de france
on a eu deux champions de france juniors
et un senior alors qu'on avait fait
aucune compétition avant est modifié à
cause de l'épidémie de kovy de 19 la
semaine s'est conclue par un challenge
en 10 grimpe et un prix à clef au centre
sportif pierre de coubertin
le résultat de cette consultation
citoyenne à verneuil-sur-seine
vernouillet échappait les habitants de
ces trois communes étaient appelés à se
prononcer sur le projet de déviation de
la route départementale 154 et c'est le
non qui l'emporté à 83% 4097 habitants
se sont exprimés pour ce scrutin qui se
déroulait par voie électronique et dans
des bureaux de vote mise en place pour
rappel le projet vise à créer une voie
de contournement pour désengorger cet
axe historique emprunté par quatorze
mille véhicules par jour est les maires
des trois communes s'oppose à cette
déviation de son côté le département des
yvelines indiqué maintenir cette
réalisation
s'agissant d'un dossier départemental et
non communal cet événement est terminée
depuis hier au niveau national mais
rassurez vous la fête de la science joue
des prolongations à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines des animations
sont prévues jusqu'à ce jeudi 15 octobre
le week-end dernier déjà un village
dédié à la science se tenait à la
commanderie installé à elancourt
eléonore si nos canons cécilia gars
tsongo pardon et justin justin brasier
pour ce sujet observer le ciel où le
soleil avec un télescope ou écouter des
lectures sur le monde de demain
la commanderie se transformer le temps
de deux après midi en village des
sciences où de nombreuses animations
étaient proposées pour les enfants
autant que pour les adultes
le but vulgariser la culture
scientifique effectivement les nations
ça peut être des grandes données très
technique mais c'est à eux il ya aussi
beaucoup de notions qui peuvent être
abordés de à tous les niveaux
vraiment les plus jeunes peuvent avoir
des notions en sciences sans pour autant
qu'on commence à les noyer sous les
formules mathématiques
cette année deux thèmes ont été retenus
l'observation scientifique et le rapport
de l'homme à la nature
l'institut national de recherche pour
l'agriculture l'alimentation et
l'environnement de versailles a profité
du village des sciences pour montrer ton
projet perception de la recherche
un projet autour des serres de recherche
de biologie végétale mais aussi une
exposition photo dédiée à la
présentation des activités des
scientifiques
au cours de la fête de la science
aujourd'hui ça nous permet de présenter
nos travaux qui sont effectués dans des
laboratoires de recherche publics et
donc de venir au contact de la société
est de présenter nos activités puisque
notre centre n'est pas accessible au
public donc on est obligé en fait si on
veut présenter nos travaux et de venir
directement voir les personnes sur des
animations comme il peut y avoir au
cours de la fête de la science par
exemple et les animations et activités
ne manquaient pas une vingtaine en tout
et de toutes sortes
on a observé le soleil et avec des
passionnés et c'est toujours cet échange
qui est très fructueux ma mère m'a dit
que il ya beaucoup de choses
intéressantes sur le sur l'espace et
l'espace ma deuxième chose préféré après
l'histoire et la mythologie elle apprend
des choses et quand ça va si on pose des
questions sur seille kolb en sera
d'autres activités sont organisées dans
les médiathèques de saint quentin en
yvelines
la fête de la science se terminera jeudi
15 octobre et ce mot avant de refermer
ce journal pour vous dire que ce
week-end c'était également la 27e
édition du festival de la bande dessinée
de buc ce soir justement le 7-8 culture
est presque entièrement consacré à ce
festival de la bd l'émission a été
tournée sur place auprès des
organisateurs des auteurs et du public
présent retrouver justine brazy avec
patrick jacques de dixmude pour les
moyens techniques pour ce 7,8 cultures
spéciales à partir de 18h30 sur tv 78
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité belle soirée avec tv
[Musique]